bro this dude's duck chess rating is
2300.
I love Eric but he is I love you too oh
my God
that's okay challenge someone why is
this so
difficult
yeah are we friends
here we go
I found him
uh challenge
he's not accepting hesitations
why why are you trying to constantly
fire me from my job oh no if you want
I'll just go
okay and that'll be that
I don't know I would walk by bodies of
water and stare at them depressed
depressing I don't know ah there we go
am I accepting challenges over there but
not okay let me not stream snipe okay
okay so how does this game work again
like you can capture the king I think
I forgot how this game works
okay
ah so the vision will increase
as I move more things
okay
it's my turn again
I should really know how this game works
Bishop D3 looks playable
okay so there's this diagonal
no he probably just moved his Pawn there
or maybe here
let's play this
okay I feel like I have decent vision
I'm playing kind of a Kali setup
wait so why is the square not visible
but the square is
wait um
because if the piece can move it should
be visible
unless he has a thing there
ah he has a pawn there that's why
oh
fancy
uh it's nothing there's no way anything
to be attacking my Bishop so even though
it's not defended
it's okay
so Bishops are probably more valuable
than Knights maybe oh no
if this move makes any sense
but to play that move I would need to
[Music]
ensure that there's no Pawn here
um
all right let's play Rook uh
I'm scared about doing anything
play A3
I think I'll play Rook B1 and B4
let's try and make some Headway
this Pawn's not so well defended
wait what oh this square is now oh
that's weird
okay
let's play this
oh this is so confusing
where he moves
oh there's a knight there wow what's
this Knight doing there
go away
there's a chance he doesn't know that I
played B4
and I might take his Knight next move
if he knows I played before
and his Knight probably moves
so we really wanna like maximize Square
control
wow
all right let's take with a knight
I don't think that changed as much
keeping my Bishops
okay it's very important to note that he
no longer has a lights for a bishop
so it's more likely I'll be able to
like trick him on the light squares
like I'd be safer playing a move like
Queen B3
unless he has a queen on this diagonal
foreign
okay so that night uh came from A5 it's
back on C6
yeah Rooks and Bishops should be more
useful in this game
I don't know he's doing though
Let's Play Bishop C2 idea Bishop oh no
let's play this
so he's a Pawn on G6 Pawn in H5
um
D5 I guess makes sense
I'm prepared Pawn B4
what are the odds he has two things
supporting the square I think it's very
unlikely
oh
okay I think I'll Castle
they probably went back here
so the pawn there
Pawn here okay so I have to keep track
of what's where and pawn here okay
I'm getting some sense of where his
things are
okay let's
not trade immediately
Bishop here could be useful
okay so there's a pawn
open file
um
play
let's play this first
so he has a dark Square Bishop in two
nights
Rooks are completely off the board
because likely the bishop will take back
oh fancy fancy okay so he could take my
queen or Bishop
let's see what's happening
so the bishop
thing is I don't know where he's like
going with his pieces
E5 okay
information
oh so he could have a knight here
so I can't quite take the pawn
liking is safer on um all I'd swear
laughs
let's take
or let's play here
I'm not going to concede the bishop here
oh no he might have a knight here
ah
let's take that
I know the pawn is capturable
I'm so scared
oh there's a bishop there okay
so I can't oh so he does have a pawn
there okay that's good to know
okay thank you very much
uh let's play this
I think I'm winning
I better be winning
I'm being extra safe
there we go
[Music]
I feel so powerful
I can see most of the board now
so his King has to be on one of the gray
squares
where's his King
is it back here oh how does King get
there what
is the king just chilling now it has to
be here
so check hee
and then can I just torture him
ah
gotta Savor the food before you consume
it
what happens if I take the king with my
king
oh yeah the pawn E4 wow unexpected Pawn
okay that was a funny game
so we can see the whole game
okay let's see what happened here so he
played Knight A5 interesting move
ah but he knew there was a Pawn on B4
and then
wow
I was too scared to take this pond
although maybe I yeah because I was
scared there's a knight on on F6
or no I was scared there and the night
might be on um H6
that Bishop C3 was a big gift
I was very fortunate there
okay
what a game